for a scene when i have to get in the  character and i have to cry for six  hours like i just listen to sad music  and it's like totally puts me in the  zone there's just some scenes and like  movies or shows that like make me cry so  i'll just like quickly re-watch i  actually got that trick from millie  because she always listens to music  before she has an emotional scene they  play music all the time when we're  filming when there's no audio and no  lines and we just have to walk or do  something dramatic they'll play this  like dramatic terminator music and it  just is perfect just gets you in the  zone and it makes everything so much  cooler